career so he made the format Sione the
social media no Adobe amo impeded
Capristo Sidibe de la ropa el mundo
inteiro Sun and Curacao to attack
Kumi pool troppo Anki a vault in Ostrava
lorry fundamentally so no Uffizi a
traversée social media rat cismo
anti-semitism oh no phobia need OB ama
ferry modo que cristo no naka de PUE [ __ ]
Bassanio Anki Timothy K social media
Reggie's Cano Acadia mu Rho D contribute
Munira determinant a cause a panic was
in tendon fat aura para pasar e al vivo
del confront corn is your zookeeper
there are prima la parola a looper que
pasa he loosed rowdy choke kakadu tow so
I contend fre in futuro equally so no
and the Scheldt a de la sua agenda poi
Serendib resident the group in Lourdes
in a bit rally Quinn de la presidenta la
commissioned in presidential commission
liberty' public in Altimas your abuse
from que representa a Presidente del
Commission yo creo que tempo
sir daddy / pour le dome and a been
interventive a sheer cat revenue de moda
Patera VA cola disposer Valerie Jose
tempo CMO and KVD fair equal contra de
mando hora de su b de la parola azure do
capital que pasa a loose Travis
proposition a pasar emo Ally demanded
thank you very much you have the floor
president tianni honorable members of
the European Parliament it's good to be
back in Europe thank you for inviting me
here today for this important discussion
now Europeans make up a large and
incredibly important part of our global
community and many of the values that
Europeans care about deeply our values
that we share from the importance of
human rights from the need for community
to the love of technology and all the
potential that it can bring now we've
always focused on all the good that
technology and connecting people can
bring and as Facebook has grown it has
helped give people ever around the world
new tools to stay connected to the
people they care about most after the
recent terrorist attacks in Berlin and
Paris London and here in Brussels tens
of thousands of people have used our
safety check tool to tell the people
they love that they're safe refugees
arriving in Europe are using Facebook to
stay in touch with their loved ones back
home and find new communities here there
are 18 million small businesses here in
Europe that use Facebook today mostly
for free almost half of whom say that
they have hired more people as a result
of their use of our tools but it's also
become clear over the last couple years
that we haven't done enough to prevent
these tools from being used for harm as
well and that goes for fake news foreign
interference and elections and
developers misusing people's information
we didn't take a broad enough view of
our responsibility and that was a
mistake
and I'm sorry for it it's going to take
time to work through all the changes
that we need to make here but I'm
committed to getting this right and to
making the significant investments that
are necessary to keep people safe
for example we are doubling the number
of people working on safety and security
at our company to more than 20 thousand
by the end of this year on top of the
investments that we're making in other
areas I expect that these increased
investments in security will
significantly impact our profitability
but I want to be clear keeping people
we'll always be more important than
maximizing our profits now let me start
by explaining the action we're taking to
prevent what happened with Cambridge
analytic from happening again back in
2014 we changed our policies to more
tightly restrict the information that
apps could get and to proactively review
all apps asking for more data so now
we're gonna go even further than this
first when you use an app it's now only
gonna get limited access to your
information your name your profile photo
and your email address unless they've
gone through a full review so that's
much less information that apps can get
on mobile platforms today second if you
haven't used an app in three months
we're gonna prevent that app from
accessing your information until you
authorize it again third last month we
showed everyone on the top of their
newsfeed
a tool with a list of all the apps that
they've used as well as a simple way to
remove permissions for any apps that
they no longer want access finally we're
investigating every single app that had
access to a large amount of people's
information before we lock down our
platform in 2014 and where we have
concerns we're going to conduct an audit
and suspend the app and if we conclude
that people's personal data was misused
we will ban the app and the developer
completely and tell everyone who is
affected so far we've investigated
thousands of apps and we've suspended
more than 200 as we work to protect
people's information we also need to
give people more control at the heart of
Europe's new data protection law the GDP
are our three important principles
control transparency and accountability
and we've always shared these values and
given people the ability to control what
information they share and who they
share it with and now we're going even
further to comply with these strong new
rules we're making the same controls and
settings available to people who use
Facebook around the world
in addition to gdpr we're also working
to give people important new controls
for example in your web browser you
already have a simple way to clear your
cookies and browsing history so we're
building a version of this for Facebook
to that we're calling clear history it
will enable you to see the information
we receive from websites and naps when
you use them and to clear this
information from your account and turn
off the ability to store it associated
with your account going forward now when
you clear your cookies in your web
browser that can make your browsing
experience worse you may have to sign
back in to every website that you use
and you know clearing your history on
Facebook may make parts of your
experience worse too but this is an
example of the kind of control that we
think that people should have and
something that privacy advocates and
regulators especially here in Europe
have long called for now let's turn to
elections in the next 18 months there
are important elections globally
including many here in Europe as well as
for the European Parliament the United
States Brazil India and Indonesia in
2016 we were too slow to identify
Russian interference on Facebook in the
u.s. presidential election at the time
we were more focused on more traditional
kinds of cyber attacks like phishing and
Malware and we identified those and we
told people but we weren't prepared
enough for the kind of coordinated
misinformation operations that we are
now aware of so since then we've made
significant operation investments to
protect the integrity of elections by
making these kinds of attacks much
harder to do on Facebook and I have more
confidence that we're gonna get this
right going forward because we've
already done a better job in several
important elections since 2016 including
the French presidential election the
German elections and the Alabama special
election in the u.s. last year we're
working with governments and other
technology companies to share
information
about threats in real-time so for
example in Germany before the 2017
elections we work directly with the JEM
the German Federal Office for
information security we're also using
new technology including AI to remove
fake accounts that are responsible for
much of the false news misinformation
and bad ads that people can see on
Facebook in the run-up to the 2017
French presidential election our systems
found and took down more than 30,000
fake accounts and in the Alabama special
election in the US we were able to
proactively detect and remove fake
accounts from Macedonia that we're
trying to spread misinformation
now it's worth adding that a lot of fake
news is is economically motivated not
politically motivated but it's much like
like email spam in that way the playbook
for fighting this is removing the ways
in which spammers can make money so then
they just go and do something else so to
do this we've banned sites that
regularly run fake news from using our
ads products so they can't make money
from it
we built our systems to penalize
clickbait and sensationalism and we also
reduce the distribution of stories and
news feed that have been rated as false
by third party fact checkers finally
we're making advertising on Facebook
much more transparent so we built a new
tool that lets you see all of the ads
that any page is running so now you can
see all of the different messages that
an advertiser or a political actor are
sending to all the different audiences
that they're trying to reach we're now
testing this in Canada and Ireland and
we're going to launch it globally this
summer increased transparency is going
to lead to increased accountability and
responsibility for all advertisers on
our systems over time now security is
not a problem that you can ever fully
solve we face sophisticated well-funded
adversaries
who are constantly evolving but we're
committed to continuing to invest
heavily and improving our techniques to
make sure that we stay ahead and we're
going to keep building tools to help
more people make their voices heard in
the democratic process as well in
addition to working on election
integrity Facebook plays a positive role
in elections around the world by helping
leaders like all of you connect directly
with voters and/or get-out-the-vote
efforts have helped millions of people
register around the world who may have
not gone to the polls otherwise I am
determined to keep building tools that
bring people together and meaningful new
ways while we work to address our safety
and security challenges as well we're
very committed to Europe almost 400
million people in Europe rely on our
services to connect and communicate with
their friends and the communities that
matter most of them Dublin is home to
our European headquarters London is home
to our biggest engineering team outside
of the United States
Paris is home to a big part of our
artificial intelligence research and we
have data centres in Sweden and Ireland
and we're building a new one in Denmark
that will come online in 2020 by the end
of 2018 Facebook will employ ten
thousand people across twelve European
cities up from 7,000 today and we will
continue to invest in Europe in the
years ahead
including we've committed to providing 1
million people in small businesses with
digital skills training by 2020 now my
priority has always been our social
mission it's connecting people helping
people build communities and working to
bring the world closer together and I
believe deeply in what we're doing and
when we address these challenges I know
that we're gonna look back and view
helping people connect and giving more
people a voice as a positive force both
here in Europe and around the world so
thank you for inviting me to the
European Parliament today
and I'm ready to take your questions
which I'm looking forward to hearing and
I'll answer together at the end thank
you the first speaker is Manfred Weber
share of the European people party here
the flow mr. Zuckerberg welcomed the
European Parliament and I want to thank
all of our president Ayane for
organizing this meeting to apologize is
a good thing and it is absolutely needed
consumers in Europe are worried
disappointed concerned about what
happened and that's why it's great that
you are here your present your showing
respect to what the U consumers there is
a good positive signal but you know that
this is not enough and you set this in
your presentation now it's about acting
the implementation of the data
protection rules which we'll get into
for this week is an important step it's
good that you are implementing now the
rules we are setting and it's also good
to hear for us as European lawmakers
that they are using the European data
protection rules for global standards so
that's good to know it's good to see in
this regard of this acting aspect I have
two very concrete questions first of all
the first question is about when you
recognized the scandal about can breach
analytics you decided to stop the access
of some of your business partners to the
database of facebook status in your
presentation of the day I want to ask
you why didn't you do it for all the
business partners so my concrete
question is my first concrete question
is is Cambridge analytical an isolated
case would you say it's the top of the
iceberg so the concrete question is can
you guarantee the do the Europeans that
another scandal will not have men three
six or nine months time a second point
in regard to this question of acting is
and I want to make a follow-up of the
questions in Washington our colleagues
did already a great job there Senator
Kamala Harris asked whether you
personally made the decision in December
2000 25 15 when you became aware about
the Cambridge analytic data breach to
not notify your users because Eddie's I
think an extremely important point
transparency that people know what is
happening with the data is crucial for
us as Europeans so we are you informed
and why no information to the users
there are the two questions I want to
put on the table on the scandal itself
I think our liebe colleagues will do a
follow-up on this that's why I want to
also come to a more general reflection
on the on the on Facebook and what it
means for our societies your company has
already today a tremendous power you
know this for example the question who
is number one on the messages and who is
number ten who is number one hundred
there you have an algorithm behind and
this rules are incomprehensible for the
moment nobody knows about them we should
I think discuss about the loss that
obliged you to make this algorithms
public in the future because when you
have so much power about who is visible
in the social media and who is not
visible that cannot be longer anymore a
decision of a company that is I think a
decision for our societies I think that
is necessary and I'm interested in your
arguments why we shouldn't do so and in
addition I want to underline that
between Europe and America we have
different understanding about what is
allowed to publish and what is not
allowed to publish in Europe for example
the question of videos and texts on
radicalization by Islamists or the
glorification of Nazi propaganda it's
unacceptable for us in Europe in America
a lot of people would say that is
covered by freedom of expression so I
see a lot of Member States for the
moment asking Facebook to voluntarily
ban these messages I think that is very
submissive we should not ask the company
to do so to delete it I think we should
clearly regulate clear rules what is
allowed in social networks in Europe and
what not and finally during your
testimony before the Congress Senator
Lindsey Graham asked you
repeatedly the name of only one of your
competitors only one without success
probably you can give us today for the
European market a competitor probably
there is one in Europe if there is
nobody in America is there today in
Europe an alternative to Facebook for
the services you are offering whatsapp
and Instagram are already part of your
empire would you consider your company
as a monopoly and I have to say is a
tech as a politician I believe in
markets and rules but I also want to
stop all kinds of possible monopolies
and that's why I think it is time to
discuss breaking facebook monopoly
because it's already too much power in
only one hand so I ask you simply and
that is my final question can you
convince me not to do so provisions of
Social Democratic mr. Zuckerberg the
reason we talk today is that your
business practices allowed for the abuse
of private data and for the misuse in
order to manipulate for political
purposes you have mentioned the progress
in European legislation are you ready to
completely comply with the new
regulation in Europe in the next three
days because this is the 25th of this
month when the general data protection
regulation enters into force can you
guarantee that Facebook is in line with
the new rules and can you guarantee that
you will not collect use and sell any
data to third parties without proper
consent especially if people want to
come off Facebook how quickly and under
what conditions will the data be fully
removed
we would like to know how can you
explain that the amount of false account
is in a rise in 2017 Facebook reported
their two to three percent of all
accounts were false accounts in 2018
this is now three to four percent what
is Facebook doing to tackle the spread
of especially sophisticated fake
accounts which allow for abuse of all
thoughts especially when it comes to
political manipulation and can you
perhaps give us the number of fake
accounts that you have been deleted so
far this year I'm personally interested
in the question of the forthcoming
European elections
you mentioned experiences in France and
in Germany which came into existence
under the pressure of the respective
governments how can you and will you
guarantee that no manipulation from
foreign and hostile interference sides
of the democratic process of your
platform ahead of the forthcoming vote
can happen are you ready to guarantee
that for the whole European Union and in
which way will you adapt your business
model that that can be prohibited from
the very instance I firmly believe that
we are at the crossroads and in a
critical situation because your business
practices touched upon two basic values
of our societies first of all the
personal data which became perhaps the
most important asset in modern media
society and secondly on the right of
self-government of sovereign nations
this is what it is about and we are
looking for your answers
now mr. Kemal kosher there OPM
conservative you on the floor Thank You
mr. Zuckerberg thank you very much for
coming to the European Parliament today
and for agreeing to send your legal and
technical expert to the civil liberties
committee and can I thank also thank
those here in the Parliament who have
made this meeting possible
now please rest assured I'm not here to
try and score some any cheap vertical
points or to have to do any stunts here
but I want to concentrate what is it
important for the many people who have
contacted me when they knew I would be
here in the room today look I'm a
libertarian minded conservative and I
believe in market-led solutions and that
bureaucracy shouldn't starve innovation
I'm also very tech oriented I'm quite
often joke that I I used to be a geek
I'm not a follower of geeks but we're
but where business takes advantage of
their users or consumers then they come
to us as politicians and they expect us
to do something at least say something
but also do something and what happened
with the Cambridge analytical case has
quite raised quite rightly raised
serious concerns now many of us do
social media
indeed I crowdsource some of the
questions today
now using social media before before I
came here but what's really interesting
has been the public outcry over
so-called shadow profiles where Facebook
collects and stores data about Internet
users that don't have or use Facebook
now I understand that Facebook admits
that you that you collect this data and
then store it for about ten days but
given that this data is collected
continuously and that most people use
internet almost every day then in effect
this becomes a continuous cycle now I
believe in self responsibility and I
know that I have my own Facebook account
I have to take some responsibility for
what I put on my own Facebook account
but what happens if I don't have a
Facebook account is the only way of
preventing Facebook collecting my data
to avoid the internet altogether or
cannot is there is there another way how
do how can non users stop Facebook
collecting their data and what do you do
then on Facebook's data do you
commercialize it and given you do that
is it morally acceptable do you think in
your opinion to collect non you know non
Facebook users data
without them know what you do with it
and are they able if I'm a non Facebook
user am I able to see the data that
you've collected on me and if not why
not
thank you I don't pour to your answers
now mister give a toast at the chair of
the group of the aliens of the liberal
arts and democracy in Europe your
diploma
Thank You president first of all my
apologies I came in in the middle of
your explanation but I was saved by
Facebook life so I followed you on
Facebook life and that was my rescue
today because of strikes in Paris so I
have to tell you mr. Zuckerberg you
remember me in fact a protagonist of a
book maybe you know that book and the
name of the protagonist mr. Calvin
Calvin is the protagonist in a book of
Dave a gift as you know the circle and
in that book it's about a big data
company and big data company who is out
of control not even the owner has
control on it and that data is used in
in elections and it seems me
very new to the reality also the fact
that maybe you have less control or no
control about your own company for the
moment because you have to apologize now
I think in total you apologize now 15 or
16 times the last decade in 2003 you've
started every year you have one or other
wrongdoing or problem with Facebook and
and you have to face the reality and to
say sorry and to say that you're gonna
fix it last year I think it was twice
that you apologize and this year you
three times already and you are still in
the month of May so it's a little bit
early in the year so what my point is
about that is are you capable to fix it
and if you have already confronted so
many dysfunctions of the system there
has to be clearly a problem and and the
only way in my opinion to do it and I'm
a liberal a free-market year is to have
public regulation to do so it's a little
bit like with the banks in the 2004 6
2010
2008 they said also now we got to do
self-regulation don't bother
no no we're gonna do it yourself the
reality is that they didn't do em
themselves and it was needed to have
tough regulation I have here an office
petition where 1 million more than 1
million citizens in Europe ask you to do
that that you accept regulation and not
to continue with the the idea are we
gonna self-regulate and I come them to
my concrete questions the first is about
the GDP our and European privacy
standards you have stool that you're
gonna apply them but are you telling the
truth in fact to us are you telling the
truth because since the outbreak of
Cambridge analytical you have massively
transfer European data of non European
citizens out from Europe away from the
European service to service otherwise in
Europe I have to tell you that's against
the regulation against GDP are and
against existing directive in Europe 95
446 who is still applicable and the same
that was mr. Kemal is saying is
happening in fact with European non
Facebook users who are in fact collected
by you and that's also against illegal
in Europe against the regulation the
second term the point is article 82 of
the GDP are you know we have to know are
taken see 82 gives the possibility of
compensation if there is a problem if
Facebook users were abused may I ask you
have you an idea will you compensate the
European Facebook users as foreseen in
article 82 of GDP our concrete question
and what will be the amount that you
will give them maybe the the value that
they have with their profile might value
have examined it might value as Facebook
user is $186 I thought it was more but
maybe my wife thing is less it could be
less my son my opponents think it's less
but many good basis what their value is
as profile could be the compensation
that you give to this
based on regulations and my third point
is about mr. Weber said it already and I
think is right you cannot convince him
because it's nonsense naturally you have
to given the example of Twitter you have
given the example I think also Google as
some of your competitors but it's like
somebody who has a monopoly in making
cars is saying look I haven't won a poll
in making cars but there is no problem
you can take a plane you can take a
train you can even take your bike so I
have no monopoly so there is a problem
there might I have two specific
questions there could you or would you
cooperate with the European and to trust
authorities to examine it and to open
your books so that we can see if yes or
no there is a monopole and secondly if
you have to split off for example
facebook messenger to give you an
example and what's app and to keep them
Instagram it should that be a good deal
for you that you could accept so finally
as my last point is a on a more personal
note I really think we have a big
problem here and it's not solved by
saying we're going to fix it ourselves
and you have to ask yourself well how
you will be remembered as one of the
three big Internet giants together with
Steve Jobs I should say and Bill Gates
who have enriched or world and all
societies or at the other hand in fact
the genius who created a digital monster
that is destroying all democracies and
of society so the moment that's a
question that you have to put yourself
for yourself okay thank you and now mr.
Lambeth go share the group of the Greens
here the floor yes mr. Zuckerberg
welcome I'll be straight I have six
binary questions I gave copy to mr.
Kaplan first of them will Facebook
commit to systematically and publicly
release data on all politically relevant
advertising in all electoral campaigns
or referendum campaign such as breaks it
or the campaign we have now in Ireland
on abortion including the amounts their
sources and their targets yes oh no well
Facebook developed a mode of operation
that allows Facebook users to completely
opt-out of targeted advertising yes or
no referring to the figures that are
doberman quoted on fake accounts with
Facebook commit to one eradicate all
remaining fake accounts by the end of
the quarter and be systematically
prevent the creation of new ones moving
forward fourth question does Facebook
provide media or curated content or on
the country is Facebook a neutral
platform here you have to choose one of
the two options fifth question will
Facebook voluntarily commit s from 2018
to publish the list of its legal
entities the number of people they
employ they turn over their profits or
losses and the taxes they pay or
subsidies they receive on a
country-by-country basis and finally
we'll fill Facebook commits to pay taxes
where it operates and generalize the
commitment you apparently recently made
to the French authorities no longer to
channel the profits made in that country
through Ireland or other tax havens
these are my six binary questions I
would welcome simple answers to them can
I ask it repeat the second question I
miss that the second one is will
Facebook develop a mode of operation
that allows end-users to completely
opt-out of targeted advertising and what
would be the condition for them but but
will you develop that option as a user I
might be interested the next speaker is
mrs. Zimmer share the confederal group
of European United Left Nordic Green
left you have the floor thank you very
much but I would like to speak in German
um Zuckerberg um Jesus meeting is at
such tanyka community cannot ask this
far involve a home Zi English kind of
until his meeting mm Boyden our mrs.
Lukash could be isn't the sphere in
einem often meeting on the battalion of
an up coordinate or the orange button
and also some common thoughts actually
hidden under this couch Ian Cohen or
Hamza sitting for I got two orbiters
wherever Angus each dozen Vysya familiar
Tom Allanson Clinton's contents the
platform does the transparent iron trade
industy communities to some buttons or
others variety of films given the
communications platform different
services artists as - Oceania
misión - are important to develop of
nama just photography Thomism
professional mechanic on human
connection was my colleague for exact
Tom miss miss Ashton does the platform
doc maravene occur can't afford enlist
in which dong Fong field fake new space
and former to own and the communities
and Clara the most important expression
practice mentioned in our - custom homes
mitten and artists I establish the
general assists of Tyvek anchor Frank
Thornton was furnished in in deutschland
in Omaha
no company herbalist in English
department a vice city of Akkad Liberty
this informations companion on the fake
news Cooper Facebook girlfriend and
untiring debate if you mention altitude
each thanking here somebody a Yamaha
Andy Jo Hoover of tomorrow the you know
Facebook meet coffins and did after to
the few at home just mentioned Joe fan
have each and staffed survival of factly
shemitah noise along the lets me our
office in inverted filling the sky chefs
model from Facebook and Trident and
the worst clinician we hadn't a
communications platform this often
dialog select Suqian author s the
solutions o homebuyers visor
um ultimate McGowan's I'm surveillance
expression her d notice course chief
Jocasta vertiginous values it's a site
and record suit seen her Facebook funny
reciter consider footage and unstaffed
unthought gaming does he ever do so far
nothing we had an improvement fans i
still here in the location when you and
evoke some kaity attacking or should
conform hospitality to us it's rocket
fizz eShop companion getting closer
untying the same Facebook understood
stars introduced us
it's this rich dish when the ice cream
muffins billion mega mansion of the
working space they start in concepts
from her house name named HD I was asked
in Africa and under the Union de Velde
practiced marijuana for my self-image
saloons of could easily Stein's cometh
million notes are piling Beckford a
skeleton passport fatiguing what's mine
and Z does he oppose act intercity
TARDIS with school for open in Geist
unbending but high esteem guys to
concrete what's mine is evoke legitimate
engines often hard each machine a
foolish off in the Netanyahu and hottest
- be given from Hong Kong infiltrate on
from Facebook or here in a location on
un médico mr. Arvind on hawkish
infiltrate on the over fusion Union
Obama dearie difference why no insist
weapons at five thousand unfrozen assent
may Union I was cooking important fuel
Lobby are right here in the occasion
when you own own to my schpeel
afters the dancers come forth noon to
four she even Americans why scientists
think it's that impressive on Facebook
what a butter em enough have exit marked
on this air shaft but aunt bottoms
either how often unhappy no I know
and let's the fog come to life sandy so
I need betoid information so sweet
and one Facebook Monica couldn't at
Wharton it's hot or not platform much
Turkish Wilson was hot Facebook icon
[Music]
success mousse thing for tsukiyojima
survivors were in format soon appear
it'sa its new car burger starter
invitato party viral a conference at the
president you know say Mary to that will
participate wrinkled a Bhutto soloist in
veto the Ontario realistic a yo fat odo
Povich at a tea party she bar equal OD a
Chitauri K you know knee force
transmission streaming a response to see
pistol a Sacramento San Saba you
critical Nigam from 3 Facebook map
decorated they were in equal a la varita
overall a parola Allen really Farage
share of the European and freedom and
direct democracy group you are the floor
I can start again mr. Zuckerberg I'm the
largest user of Facebook and all the EU
institutions in terms of followers in
terms of engagement so I'm your best
client here in the room I've no idea of
the value of that but I'm pleased to see
you as I hope you are me the one slight
problem I have I'm watching very
carefully but testimony that you gave on
Capitol Hill time it again
people asked you you know is this
genuinely a neutral political platform
and you come up with the same line again
and again it's well-crafted
you say that Facebook is a platform for
all ideas now historically of course
it's true that through Facebook and
other forms of social media there is no
way
that brexit or trump or the italian
elections could ever possibly have
happened it was social media that
allowed people to get round the back of
mainstream media now perhaps you're
horrified by this creation of yours on
what it's led to I don't know but what
is absolutely true is that since January
of this year you change your modus
operandi you've changed your algorithms
and it has led directly to a very
substantial drop in views and
engagements for those that have got
right-of-center political opinions the
facts are very clear just look at
President Trump's numbers on a much
smaller scale look at mine look at
thousands of other conservative
commentators and on average we're down
about 25% over the course of this year
and you know that's happening on a
platform for all ideas I am NOT talking
here mr. Zuckerberg about extremism I'm
not talking about encouraging violence
I'm not talking about hatred of anybody
I'm talking about people who have
majority mainstream opinions and frankly
I feel they are being willfully
discriminated against what interests me
is who decides what is acceptable who
are these people you referred to earlier
these third party fact checkers who are
these people
I mean why is there no transparency in
this process at all I'm not generally
somebody that calls for legislation on
the international stage but I'm
beginning to wonder whether we need a
social media bill of rights to basically
protect free speech and I'm asking you
today very very clearly that would you
accept that today Facebook is not a
platform for all ideas that is operated
impartially
Thank You mr. father now mr. Nikola we
don't have a lot of time please
now the next speaker is mr. Nicola
Nicola be a co-chair of the European
nation and freedom group Quebec la
posesión de donate V de Manos measure
tokido toda la madre palace altar
proceed owe me pre-christian Coelho
Hospital ibut a fundamental vote Rizzo
socials vida de marrón position Lucas
Lima no pardo de novo station Demong
crayons in fondo de todos see Rosetta
not Facebook a tuna Gauguin American
platform dashes a data connection la
liberté expression e condition la
liberté deformation until a suppression
impasse Facebook a tautology Lou docken
second by example addiction in
publication tell Cardinal música burgoo
survey volcania calchas asto decision a
Sunday Mass at another [ __ ] Ottumwa
prepared the essence of reckons
King OTT blocky say merci lepers
Facebook de mundo francais general so
don t tanto buscamos supreme a a local
imagination sad spectacular may profit
more legally Pacific cannoli problem
Megatron Sebastian Villopoto producer
Miliband especially on the eve hesitant
donate a total eat a composed a new
movement on question NFL paella
consultation the party organization
legal CPA Vegeta visitor than axel Eva
Allahu Allah tells opinion kiss extreme
non-associative
programs here an opiate of telephonic
decorate a usual on Marquez available
material but in a pastor's palace option
politic Dominic Renea katha pollitt rock
concert in possibility a different enemy
on a daily dose at Caesarea Rose it
possesses the pivot is assured on our
Liberty
order to control additional Parliament a
prisoner Alma
Evette inacceptable colleague a Faton
deposit in soto de cemento Prive resulta
que hace Mme phobia Aldea Aditya less
detonation Masuka a vote responsibility
Diwali media et cetera the water
platform
edit Emo's a la Duchesse de cosas de
book licensure arbitrary party kappa
facebook and cooperative avec a passive
solar motto no democracy party viva la
decisión unilateral the supreme oedipus
facebook epilim am the opinion regime
CalPERS material presented shock therapy
de la shutter effect news travel
inaudible away evoke a $2 metal paddle
new and new vocal text for restful
al-qaeda montage liberated ex questioned
opinion yeah another four speakers leads
me to respect the timing the first is
mrs. Dodds non-attached of the members
here the floor
Thank You mr. president and thank you
mr. Zuckerberg for appearing here today
I am a member of this parliament from
Northern Ireland in the United Kingdom
and while many of my colleagues here
today have focused on elections and the
issues of Facebook and public policy I
want to take you in a slightly different
direction in my question today in a few
weeks time a family within my
constituency will mark the third
anniversary of the loss of their son to
online bullying
his name was Ronan and he was 17 years
old when he died he was the victim of a
false Facebook account from online
bullies who persuaded him to send an
intimate photograph of himself and
and then asked for three thousand pines
in return for not posting this on his
Facebook account
Romans family have been incredibly brave
in publicizing this case and in dealing
with this situation but this is only one
example of the rise of false accounts
within Facebook and I would like you to
tell us today what you're doing to stop
the rise of false Facebook accounts
which deliberately target young and
vulnerable people Noland clearly felt he
had nowhere to go can you explain to us
then as well I'm in light of this
phenomenon which is a terrible thing
right across Europe can you explain to
us what you're doing to work with
third-party organizations to try and
educate people in safety in using the
Internet and would you tell us whether
or not you're content that other
families represented around this room
here today will have the children kept
safe by the settings and default
settings that you use on on your
particular site and I just very quickly
also say we live in a Europe in the rise
of anti-semitism in the rise of
terrorism much of it conducted and much
of the information conducted online in
the last few weeks you've said that
you've taken down a lot of that hateful
and offensive comment from your site can
you tell us how you define acceptable
comment on the site what are the
benchmarks she used and whether or not
Facebook actually is capable of
regulating this for itself
now mrs. Cecilia weeks on share of the
conference that committee chair you have
the phone thank you very much mr.
president and thank you also for
organizing
and sharing this meeting with us tonight
thanks to you mr. su confirm for having
agreed to appear and to answer to our
questions we appreciate that a lot it is
it has been already stated many times
but it must be underlined again that it
is essential that EU citizen can trust
that their integrity and their rights on
the Internet are being protected
especially since the EU new rules on
data protection are entering into force
in only three days as from now I'd like
to raise two questions to you mr.
Zuckerberg firstly the scandal involving
Facebook and Cambridge analytic ah is
more than anything else an issue of
ethics and values you said in your
intervention in the hearing with the US
Congress you repeated it here tonight
that Facebook is responsible for the
content on the platform once Facebook
requests other companies to delete users
data does Facebook follow up to check
compliance by these companies and how
will you ensure that this is really done
and secondly I am convinced that GU
citizens would like to know which
specific measures with that will be
taken by Facebook to ensure that a
scandal like this one Cambridge analytic
I will not occur again you have shared
your vision in spirit on on greater
responsibility on what happens on the
platform but mr. Zhu can but can you
guarantee to the millions of users many
of them EU citizens that company will
take all the necessary steps to ensure
that civil rights and liberties
according to EU standards and and that
Facebook fully will comply to the gdpr
and when this will happen it would be
good to have a date when full compliance
is is ensured
thank you and now mr. Amash chair did he
become a teacher of the floor thank you
very much president Thank You mr.
Zuckerberg for being here and we hope
that our committee will examine further
with Facebook executives and so on
death and this is for people are
watching this web streamin want a more
in-depth investigation they mr. Faraj
slightly characteristically talked about
i prolifically wasn't facebook i may be
the most modest user of Facebook in the
room but our committee is not modest in
any way we are celebrating this week
gdpr but I do want to mention that GDP
are in my view and we have the reporter
here is not something that will impact
entirely on your business model and I
think you know this privacy is essential
also and there's a reason I mention any
privacy is because there is a regulatory
framework here and I want to mention
something very obvious you're not in the
congressional hearing you've come to the
European Union and there's a big
difference and the difference mentioned
by some of my colleagues I want to make
very explicit and that is that we are
here in terms of regulation and the
United States is here and this gap is
very obvious it's obvious that our
adequacy agreements is obvious in the
day-to-day transactions we have between
the continents but for you it is a real
detailed question of how you will comply
now I know that you will say of course
we're going to comply with GDP our but
there's a much bigger task that I think
people are estimating and no doubt the
reporter will say something about that
in a moment now in your introduction you
spoke I think quite eloquently about
what you thought was one of the key
points which was the app question and I
think you mentioned it because it is
really the critical point what I wanted
to ask and colleagues are talking about
crowdsourcing questions the question
I've been asked by individuals
journalists and others is whether the
question of protection of privacy and
the rules on facebook apps which you
were asked in Congress is actually the
tip of the iceberg or as they're a
bigger iceberg now you're addressing
this because it's important so I really
do need to repeat this because
specifically given that Facebook was
forced to review the apps authorized on
the platform out I'll be quick president
this is the problem about going last of
course following this the Cambridge
analytical scandal and now that you've I
think you blocked around 200 of these
apps since the congressional hearings
come here having brought 200 of them I
mean isn't this first of all a clear
signal that Facebook failed to protect
the privacy of his users we have 252
million I think in the European Union
that's more than in the United States
and it gives us the question of that you
should really provide us with the
detailed measures and you have of some
of these that Facebook will implement to
ensure a thorough analysis of apps that
are allowed on Facebook and really why
did you not inform users of these
problems to enable them to take measures
to protect their data the president if
you just allow me the bottom line for
you I think of for facebook is we need
to know in Europe the true scale of the
violations of users data by third-party
apps we need to get an estimate of this
and we need to know what it means to
commit to GDP our if I just give you one
example the GDP our gives individuals a
right to access and verify all the data
a company holds on them and that
includes not just their profiles
mentioned by another colleague but also
the marketing profiles data that was not
disclosed by the user but interpreted
from his or her behavior are you really
going to give users full access to their
marketing profiles are you going to do
or complete all of the steps in GDP our
never mind
privacy and really want to just to say
in conclusion here the question of the
difference between GDP our and what is
in the United States the gap must be
closed but for you given that you are
here and I tried to be brief because we
will go in more depth is it's not just
that you have to comply with GPR and GDP
are but you have to remember that you're
here in the European Union where we
create a GDP our so we ask you to make a
legal and moral commitment if you can to
uphold EU data protection law to think
about a privacy to protect the privacy
of European users and the many millions
of European citizens and non Facebook
users as well and this is a moral and
legal
Legation and implementation and I really
ask you to think about this because
you've come here not to Congress but to
the European Union and we have
expectations thank you last question mr.
Albert a report for the general data
protection regulation we are the for me
thank you very much mr. president and
thank you mr. Zuckerberg for being with
us here tonight and I'll keep it as
short as possible to us for all the
questions to be answered because I
really think there have been many very
important questions to be answered so
three precise questions first I welcome
a lot that Facebook is applying the
principles of the GD P R in future
globally in its global business I I
think that is a very important step
ahead I hope that it is complying with
the GDP our globally because I could
pose the question if you as a US
consumer should not get equal treatment
to EU users I think many US colleagues
or users will post the same question
soon the first real question will you
with Friday the GDP are kicking in
assured that no facebook user of future
Facebook user has to give consent for
the processing of personal data more
than what is necessary to use the
service because today we have very often
the problem that there is to take it or
leave it situation and with the GPR that
is not really what we want to see
anymore you need to give consent for
everything what is not necessary to use
the service second and the US Senate's
you responded to this question we
collect some data for security purposes
so to one of the question we collect
some data for security purposes and we
keep it can you promise that this data
which you keep for security purposes is
not used for other services for other
purposes like targeted advertisement
and last but not least repeatedly
European courts have demanded the
separation of users data between
Facebook and whatsapp after your company
has acquired what's up will you promise
to me and also the European whatsapp and
Facebook users that from Friday onwards
there won't be any exchange across use
of users personal data between the two
services thank you very much thank you
very much I think it's important for us
to be at the center of the political
debate for another time the European
Parliament is they are - the democracy
in Europe I think this political debate
is very very important of not only for
the European Parliament and also for the
European citizens for this I want to
thank you for the question and now the
floor is yours all right president eonni
and and honourable members you've raised
a lot of important questions and I'm
going to try to use the remainder of our
time to get through as many of them as I
possibly can
a number of you asked a questions around
inappropriate content on Facebook in one
form or another whether that's hate
speech or bullying or terrorism or
different content and how that relates
to this or fake accounts and how this
relates to this position on philosophy
of needing to take a broader
responsibility first let me be clear the
the bottom line here is that hate speech
bullying terror violence all this
content has no place on our on our
services but in order to really execute
that we need to upgrade and do a better
job of executing our policies so if you
look back at the history of how we've
operated and when I got started in my
dorm room in college because it was just
me and because we didn't have the AI
tools at the time to be able to go look
through a lot of the content and
understand what was in violation of our
community standards and what wasn't our
policy for most of the history of the
company has been to have our community
flag things for us and then us to look
at them reactively so
if someone sees something that that they
thought might be hate speech or bullying
they would flag that and then we would
look at that we've built up teams to
manage that but now we think that our
responsibility is greater and and now
sitting here in 2018 we have the ability
to start developing more AI tools which
I'll get to in a moment some more detail
to be able to flag more of the content
upfront and now is a is a big company we
also have the ability to employ tens of
thousands of people to go review more of
this content so if you look for example
at terror content one of the things that
that I'm proud of is that our AI systems
have now can flag 99% of the Isis and
al-qaida related content that that we
end up taking down before any person in
our community flags that for us another
example is around bullying ma'am we had
this really unfortunate set of incidents
when we first launched Facebook live
where we saw that people were harming
themselves or or committing suicide on
live and we realized that we needed to
do a much better job of addressing that
quickly so we built AI tools and tools
to determine if someone was thinking
about harm or suicide hired 3,000 people
to make it set the response time that we
could get to those live videos is now
less than 10 minutes and that has been
one area where we've been able to
significantly improve but we're
basically going through each of these
areas starting from the areas that are
the most sensitive and have the have the
highest risk of harm terror bullying
self-harm election integrity which is is
obviously extremely important our
prioritizing them first by our goal over
the coming years is going to get to
developing the AI systems and hiring the
staff necessary to be able to
proactively review more of the content
as it's coming into into the system will
never be perfect on this you know our
adversaries especially on the election
side people are trying to interfere will
have access to some of the same AI tools
that we will
so it's an arms race and we'll need to
constantly be working to stay ahead but
our vision for how we should manage the
system is going to move from one of
reactive management as people in our
community flag things to one where we're
more proactively having systems look at
the content flag things for tens of
thousands of people to review and we're
already making significant progress in
doing that now a number of you mentioned
specifically issues around fake news so
I want to talk a little bit about our
roadmap for for addressing this because
the bottom line here is that nobody on
Facebook or off facebook wants fake news
right no one will sit here and say that
they that they that they want the
information that they see to be false so
you know we've broken down the problem
and do we think that there are three
main sources of content that are
problematic here the first is is just
spam which I touched on a little bit in
my opening statement and this is it's
often it's not politically motivated or
ideologically motivated it's
economically motivated it's people who
are just trying to make money by coming
up with the most sensationalist content
they can and putting it out there so the
way you fight this is the same roadmap
that companies have used to fight email
spam you can take away these spammers
profit motive and then they go do
something else and we've done a number
of things like preventing them from
using Facebook Ads decreasing the
distribution to do this the second
category is fighting fake accounts
because what we found is that when
people are using fake accounts on our
system there's less accountability and
they're more likely to spread bad
information misinformation interact in
ways that are interfering in elections
and things like that so we develop
systems both to identify fake accounts
as they're being registered and we just
released a transparency report where we
said that we took down I think it was in
the first quarter of this year about 580
million fake accounts the vast majority
within minutes of being registered as
our systems are able to identify that
well we also have a significant
operation which is working on
identifying fake accounts that get
through that initial filter so we can
identify them all
once they're in the Facebook community
our best estimate today but I think is
is that it's a single-digit percent of
the accounts but we're constantly
working on improving our tools to be
able to identify that and that's
extremely important as well so you have
spammers you have fake accounts the last
category is people who are well-meaning
but just happen to share something that
is provably false and they're you know
we don't want to be in a position as
Facebook of saying what is true or false
leaving that that's not the right
position for us to be in so we want to
work with third party fact checkers and
we're public with with who all the fact
checkers are - one of the questions that
that there was earlier and if a number
of third party fact checkers all
identify that a piece of news is
provably false then we'll append
something to the story to make sure that
we show more related content that people
can have a more rounded view or
understand that fact checkers have
marked that story is true and we'll try
to show it less now we're trying to roll
that out around the world that requires
having specific fact-checking partners
in every country and in every language
so we're constantly rolling out more
each month and we have a lot more to do
here and we're we know that there's a
lot more to do there all right
then there were a number of questions
around elections so I know that there
are a lot of important elections coming
up and in Europe you know I think in
2019 and 2018 there are elections in
Slovenia and Sweden's Latvia Estonia
Belgium Poland and of course the
European Parliament and this is one of
our top priorities as a company is just
making sure that we that we do that we
prevent anyone from trying to interfere
in elections like the Russians were able
to in the u.s. presidential election in
2016 and I outlined some of the roadmap
for that earlier the game plan is a
combination of building more AI tools to
identify fake accounts that are trying
to interfere and take them down like we
did in the French presidential election
where we identified and took down
more than 30 thousand accounts a
playbook of closer operation and
cooperation with Federal Election
Commission's like we executed in the
German elections in 2017 and increased
transparency which we think is is going
to be very important you know if you
have the ads that every political actor
or advertiser is trying to run to every
audience be public then there's just
more accountability and if someone is is
is trying to do that as a fake account
it becomes more apparent if someone as a
as a legitimate political cop political
actor is just sending different messages
to different groups that will be
transparent so we think that that
greater accountability is important and
that set of transparency tools that
we're building we're going to be rolling
out around the world globally this
summer so we're we're optimistic about
that we think that there's probably more
to do to add on to those after the first
version but we think that that first
version is going to take us quite far as
well I think ok so then there were a
number of questions about regulation you
know there you know some of the
questions asked how I view regulation I
don't think the question here is whether
or not there should be regulation I
think the question is what is the right
regulation I think the Internet is
becoming increasingly important in
people's lives some sort of regulation
is important and inevitable and the the
important thing is to get this right
right and to make sure that we we have
regulatory frameworks that help protect
people that are flexible so that they
allow for innovation that don't
inadvertently prevent new technologies
like AI from being able to develop and
of course to make sure that that new
startups right so the next students
sitting in a college dorm room like I
was 14 years ago doesn't have an undue
burden on being able to to build the
next great the next great products so
we've that's really important and that's
an ongoing conversation that we look
forward to to participating in
there were a couple of questions around
competition and and and how we view our
role and and in our position as a
platform here and to that I'd say it's a
few things one is first is that we exist
in a very competitive space where people
use a lot of different tools for
communication or the average person uses
about eight different tools for
communication ranging from all sorts of
private messaging up to more broadcast
mediums to things where they're
communicating with groups of people and
and that all their friends at once so
from where I sit it feels like there are
new competitors coming up every day
there are competitors that reach tens
and hundreds of millions of people and
we're constantly needing to evolve our
service in order to stay relevant and
serve people well so that feels like
it's a competitive environment where
there are many choices that people have
on the business side the business model
is advertising Facebook today is about
six percent of the global advertising
market so clearly advertisers also have
a lot of choice in terms of where they
choose to to advertise and and that's an
important lines to look at it from as
well although I think that you want to
look at it both from the consumer choice
perspective and that the business choice
one thing that I want to add that I
think often gets overlooked when you
talk about competition is you know
around the world there are 70 million
small businesses that use Facebook's
tools to grow and reach customers and in
Europe alone there are about 18 million
small businesses that use Facebook tools
and and as I said my opening statement
about half of them have told us that
they're hiring more people because of
their use of our tools to be able to
grow so I think it's important not to
lose track of when you're thinking about
competition that there's the element in
the internet space and in the
advertising space but there's also the
extremely Pro competitive effect of
enabling all these small businesses to
now have access to the same kinds of
marketing and advertising tools and be
able to reach customers in sophisticated
technological ways that previously only
businesses have the means to do and
that's something that we're very proud
of that we can that we can provide as
something that levels the playing field
and I think when you're thinking about
the the overall ecosystem and
competition there I think that that's a
very important part to take into account
there were a number of questions about
taxes so I want to touch on that briefly
as well Facebook has has always paid
taxes in all of the countries where we
have operations set up we pay all taxes
required by law and we invest heavily in
Europe all right we're gonna have more
than 10,000 employees across Europe and
12 cities by the end of this year we
have two data centers or we have data
centers already in Sweden and Ireland
and we're building another one in
Denmark that's gonna be online in 2020
so we we've always paid the taxes that
the law requires and we were making
significant investments in in in terms
of helping to build the the economies
and in the countries here and to to
contribute to the the innovation and and
job birth here as well all right let me
see what else is there okay there were a
few questions about GDP are the you know
the principles here are around control
transparency and accountability
you know the idea you know a number of
you asked it when we expect to be fully
compliant with GDP our regulations we do
expect to be fully compliant on May 25th
so in three days from now
we've had a large team working on this
inside Facebook to make sure that we're
compliant and you know one of the things
that that we've wanted to make sure in
rolling this out is because one of the
things that the law requires here in
Europe is that someone has to go through
these extensive flows before they can
use the service starting on May 25th and
one of the pieces of feedback that we
got from people in the community was
that didn't want to get road blocked
before seeing before being able to go
see their friends content right if
you're coming to face because you want
to share something you know the last
thing that we want is for someone to to
go through the flow is quicker than they
need to
and and just you know click okay or no
on a bunch of stuff because they they
just want to blow through that in order
to get to what they were trying to do so
we've actually been rolling out the GDP
our settings and flows for a while now
and a large percent of Europeans have
already gone through them and we've get
we've basically put the flows in front
of people and given them the opportunity
to dismiss them starting on May 25th we
will start requiring people to go
through the flows before they can resume
using our services so a number a large
percent of people dozens of percents
have gone through the flows already and
we've gotten we've gotten good feedback
on on that and and and how we've
implemented that so far let me see if
there's anything else that that is
important to touch on there are there
were a couple of questions about about
political bias that I want to touch on
because I think that this is a very
important topic as as a couple of you
mentioned we are committed to being a
platform for all ideas that means that
we want to make it so that that people
can come to to our service and and share
any idea across the political spectrum
it's very important to me that we're a
service that allows for a wide variety
of political discourse we view that as a
a big part of our responsibility and I
can commit to you here today that we
will that we we have never and will not
make decisions about what content is
allowed or how we do ranking on the
basis of of a political orientation so
that that's that's an important
philosophical point for me that that I'm
that I'm proud to be able to commit to
there was a specific point around around
distribution and reduction of seeing
people's content and on that would I
just say is we've made a number of
changes this year to make sure that
we're showing people's friends and
family and community content more than
public content in general so a lot of
the feedback that we've heard from
people
is that they come to Facebook because
they want to stay connected to people
we've also done a lot of well-being
research this wasn't a topic that came
up today but we're very focused on
making sure that people's use of
technology is good for for people's
well-being and and is not taking away
from it in some way and all the research
that we have shows that when you're
using the Internet to stay connected to
people that you care about that's good
for your well-being it's correlated with
measures like increased measures of
health and happiness and feeling more
connected and less alone over time but
when you're just using Facebook or the
Internet overall to read news or
passively consume videos that isn't
correlated with those same benefits to
well-being so because of that and
because of feedback that we've received
we've made a number of shifts to the to
the services to promote connecting with
people's friends and family and
communities more than public content so
that has led to reductions in
distribution for public content video
news across the board and is not
targeting any specific political
ideology is there anything else 7
proposed shadow proposed
I capture so silly it's your to your
question the forum for the content that
that website synapse sent us we think
it's very important that people have the
ability to clear this so we just
launched or just announced that we're
we're building and will soon launch this
clear history feature that allows you to
clear all basic browsing history data to
your point about earlier around you know
how do we separate out the security data
you know it's it's very important that
we don't have people who aren't Facebook
users about coming to our service and
trying to scrape the public data that's
available so one of the ways that we do
that is you know people use our service
and and even if they're not signed in we
need to understand how they're using the
service to prevent that activity and
that's you know a big theme of today has
been around making sure that we can do a
better job of governing the system
keeping bad content out one of the ways
that we do that is by is by
understanding how people are using are
using the system but if you'll know the
Facebook user how do you stop that day
to be transferred on a security side we
think it's important to keep it to
protect people in our community were
there any other themes that we want to
get through I mean there's what some
right that's good so there were a number
of questions around what whether
Cambridge analytic Oh was the tip of the
iceberg or whether we expect there to be
more apps that have misused data on this
you know the good news with Cambridge
analytic is that the changes that we
made back in 2014 would prevent a new
app like Cambridge like well camera dead
Mallika wasn't an app but was that
there's an app developer who used the
platform and then sold the data to
Cambridge analytic Oh which is is it
there's the whole other thing but it
wouldn't be possible for an app
developer to get access to that level of
data since after our 2014 platform
changes went into effect but because
there were a lot of different apps that
were using the system before 2014
and before the changes went into effect
in 2015 we think it's important now to
go back and investigate every single app
that had access to a large amount of
people's personal data before we lock
down the platform so that's what we're
in the process of doing
we've already investigated thousands of
apps and as I said earlier we've taken
down more than 200 there were many
thousands more that we need to
investigate this is going to take many
months I do anticipate that there are
going to be other apps that we find that
we're going to want to take down and
this is why we're going now and doing
this full investigation is this is part
of our shift towards not just about
trying to manage the system reactively
of having we've always had the ability
for people in our community to flag apps
that they thought were bad actors to us
and then we would look at them we've
we've had the ability to and we've we've
done audits of apps in the past we've
had a Content review and app app review
team but now what we're doing is taking
a much more proactive approach so rather
than waiting for people in the community
to flag for us that there may be issues
we are going through and investigating
ourselves upfront all the different apps
that had access to a large amount of
information we were upfront reviewing
every app that asked for access to
additional people's information and
anywhere where we see any concerns we're
going to bring in third-party auditors
to conduct a full audit to determine if
there was any misuse of people's
personal information and if there was we
will ban those apps and and tell
everyone who is affected I want to be
sensitive to time because we are 15
minutes over the the the scheduled
meeting I think that this was this
iroh's that there were a lot of specific
questions that that I didn't get to
specifically answer but you know going
around and hearing the themes of what
people were are concerned about and had
questions about I think I was able to to
address the high level areas in each and
I'll make sure that we follow up with
each of you afterwards to make sure that
your specific questions get addressed
and we're gonna have someone
come to to do a full hearing soon to
answer more the technical questions as
well so thank you again for I think
there was one question raised by a giver
who said and we say that's linked to my
question and that's the separation of
different services and that I think it's
a very important question in this round
the market power of Facebook and the
question if you cross use for example
data between Facebook and whatsapp so it
would be good if you say at least one
word to that will you allow users to
escape targeted advertising I mean I
asked you six yes and no questions I got
not a single answer and of course well
you asked for this format well for a
reason okay I'll make sure we follow up
and get your answers to those okay I
think I want to ask you if it's possible
to have right answer for any question
from from you yes in the next days we
have all well-prepared for intervention
so we have them on paper we could mr.
president you collect you give them to
the team of mr. suka Berto mr.
Zuckerberg himself and we receive
written answers on it because let's be
honest I have not so much I don't think
that the right ways to say and now we're
gonna put it in Libya and so on now
there are a number of questions has been
put by other colleagues that I want an
institute that said I'm anxious of this
new brave new world that mr. Zuckerberg
has presented us a brave new war
what tens and tens of thousands of
private people are scrutinizing us and
are saying what is fake news what is not
fake news what is hate speech what is
not hate speech mr. generation of this
discussion in this format as well as in
the Liebherr format this is very obvious
I think first of all
but is it possible to talk to it with
answer based on by Christians with a
right answer
bye-bye mr. duChemin in the next days
for every question okay competition for
example a European antitrust thing
that's important do we need I think
we're gonna push or antitrust ad agency
to go into this if there is no good
answer to I think the problem is the
timing for me if a firm is possible to
say that there is a flight but I think
if sorry I think this is the format if
do you agree mr. Joe cable for right
answer in the next days for a question
by question is possible to write the
question okay yeah okay thank you very
much